[Musique]
à l'heure des bouées des facteurs et des
premières éditions des journaux la
plupart des français encore mal réveillé
commencent leur journée
mais là commence t-il bien monsieur que
prenez vous le matin pour votre petit
déjeuner au lit sans manger
non non qu'est ce qui te réveilles le
matin la fin pour ces mamans qui
viennent réveiller parce que sinon je
n'ai pas très fort le motard mais c'est
quand jacques ans je sens l'odeur cela
n'a pas envie de manger manger quoi
depuis longtemps le traditionnel petit
déjeuner français préoccupe les
diététiciens préoccupations évoquées aux
derniers entretiens de bichat par le
docteur astier dumas les enfants
français notamment partent pour une
grande part d'entre elles étalent après
avoir pris un café avec un peu de lait
et une date
il faut pourtant que les parents
prennent conscience du fait que le petit
déjeuner fait partie de l'alimentation
générale que l'alimentation doit être
répartie en trois repas et non assurés
d'une façon préférentielle ou au repas
du soir au repas de midi
par exemple le petit déjeuner doit
apporter environ le quart de la ration
calorique mais certainement le quart de
la ration prothétique
car c'est de la peur protidique de son
optimum que dépend la tension et le
potentiel de réaction de l'enfant à la
fin de la matinée
je crois qu'il ya deux choses qu'il faut
dessus on dire aux parents c'est que
tous les enfants doivent prendre du lait
le café ne leur apportent rigoureusement
viennent ensuite qu'il faut leur dire
que les eaux ne font pas mal au fond est
gelé
qui quand ils sont bur ceux qui se
lèvent très tôt ne change pas non plus
leurs habitudes
une tasse de café avalé au saut du lit
est beaucoup plus tard le casse croûte à
l'heure du café du thé et des tartines
pour la majorité des autres
les horaires de travail commande peut
être la journée continue
transformera-t-elle le petit déjeuner en
attendant rebutés par les vitamines les
protéines ou les hydrates de carbone
désorientés par les publicités
contradictoires qui leur vante les
vertus d'aliments condamné par les
diététiciens les français préfèrent
continuer comme avant
persuadé au fond d'eux mêmes qu'au lieu
de chercher à s'adapter au rythme trop
rapide de la vie moderne
il vaudrait mieux ralentir ce rythme et
retrouver l'envié de manger avec le
temps de manger
[Musique]